since i see
a few people still joining we wait for
three to four minutes more and then we
begin with our session
thank you
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all
to the session of cyanics club before
starting with today's session i would
like to brief you all about
who are we and what do we do cyanics
club is a bioinformatics and data
science student led club
that originated in india our main goal
is to help students learn about
bioinformatics
gain its practical knowledge through
group sessions
debates easy to take courses and
ultimately
put out push their limits of the
students beyond
you know textbook limits and critical
push their critical thinking limits as
well
we also aim at encouraging young minds
to push their critical thinking limits
beyond the school and college curriculum
now i am rudy raja president of psionics
club
i am a student of integrated biomedical
sciences
and if anyone is interested to join the
club they can join the club by the
following this whatsapp group link or
else you can even email me on the email
id stated over here
also we do not have any age restrictions
for joining the club hence we welcome
all ages because we believe that
knowledge has no boundaries
what do we do in psionics club so we
have interactive sessions on zoom
in which we interact with people from
various backgrounds
we also have certain kinds of groups and
debates
we have certain kinds of omixlogic
training programs that comprises of
introduction to bioinformatics genome
mixed methyl genomics transcriptomics
and a very new course introduced that
its bytes and molecules
so we understand biological treasure in
such a way that it would help us to put
that exactly into our practical lives
moving on the topics that we cover in
cyanics club
are about mainly focused on infectious
disease
oncology neuroscience science
we also have topics related to genomics
and microbiology
our main aim is to help students to
clear concepts about bioinformatics
how can they use tools about hands-on
directive sessions is also what we
conduct
we have brainstorming sessions that help
the group of students to enhance their
critical thinking
abilities and also we have certain kinds
of programs that have
shown applications of coding in
bioinformatics so if students are
interested in them we also provide that
in order cyanics club aims at helping
students
learn bioinformatics from ground zero
we also provide free courses on omics
logic and pine biotech platform
namely introduction to bioinformatics
and introduction to genomics
they are self-learning introductory
courseworks and anyone can take them
they are available for free on the
website
so what do we usually do in cyanics club
we have group discussions we have review
report writing on certain kinds of
biological literature in order to
apprehend them well we have debate on
certain kinds of mind-boggling
arenas in bioinformatics comprises of
like
waxing bioinformatics and technology and
further on
we also have presentations on certain
crucial research topics and research
papers
our research interns who are doing
projects with pine biotech have also
been asked to present
in cyanics club we also discuss an
exchange ideas for project development
and students can take their ideas
further and work on
a hands-on project
so now i would like to this session is
currently based on the theme cancer
biology
today our research interns and our
mentors
including and also i would be presenting
upon certain themes that are based on
oncology and the ongoing projects
to present first i would like to invite
sreyashi banerjee and sroshi banerjee
who are doing the project based on
cancer biology
that is breast cancer as a team
to start with srayasi banerjee
and siroshi banerjee both are from west
bengal
currently pursuing their masters in
biochemistry from reward university
bangalore
sreyashi is interested in bioinformatics
and its
application in the drug development
field and rosi is interested in
bioinformatics application and its use
in drug development
also for cancer and its treatment i
invite suryashi and serosa banerjee
to please share their screen and take
their presentation forward thank you
yeah i'll be sharing my screen right now
yes
so are we seeing something i don't see
any
slides being shown
it's taking some time
try resharing it
yeah in case you have a problem with me
you can also share the screen right
yes i can share the screen for them
okay i think you should start share the
screen
and shushy and shroushi you can then
continue with the presentation yeah sure
okay thank you
is my screen visible yeah it's visible
yeah yeah so uh this is me shreyashi
banerjee i'm a student of rewa
university
and currently i'm pursuing my final
semesters and master's degree in
biochemistry
and uh and here i'm
shioshi banerjee currently pursuing a
masters in
biochemistry from reward university
i did my bachelor's from
utah university and now shyoshi banichi
will be explaining
some main points for breast cancer
now what is basically what is breast
cancer
it is a breast cancer is the most common
malignant
condition of breast after skin cancer
breast cancer is the most uncontrollable
most common cancer that is diagnosed in
the united states
the causes mainly for the breast cancer
can be
hormonal factors like uh when cells
divide more rapidly than healthy cells
too
and then they continue to accumulate
forming a lump or
mass cells uh may spread through the
breast
to our lymph nodes to other parts of the
body
there are different types of breast
cancers that is ductal
carcinoma in situ invasive ductal
carcinoma
inflammatory breast cancer and
metastatic
breast cancer now uh risk
the risk for the breast cancers like
passive smoking releases
benzopyrene drinks that causes breast
cancer in women
then radiation treatment to the chest as
a child
increases the breast cancer heredity
hereditary uh having dense breast
symptoms can be a lump in the breast or
in
underarm thickening or swelling of part
of the breast
irritation of breast skin then changes
in the size or shape
blood discharge from nipples and
also newly inverted nipple
and morphological changes in the organ
okay our next slide
for now coming to the mutations that
causes breast cancer
that can be uh bracha one and bracket 2
these are the most common cause of
hereditary
breast cancer that is inherited
these are the inherited mutation in the
bracha 1 or bracha 2 gene
in normal conditions this genes help to
make proteins that
repair the damage dna also the mutated
versions of this genes can lead to
abnormal
cell growth that leads to cancer also
the another
gene mutation that causes breast cancer
is
mutation in p53 uh the frequency of this
is
a very less and now
she will be explaining the next
bioinformatical approach
for breast cancer yeah
so in bioinformatical approach uh what
we do is we compare
unknown sequences of dna uh from a
collection of samples
and then we compare with the control and
we identify the mutated sequences
and illustration of the expression
profiles are done uh that is mainly
uh for breast humorogenesis and through
bioinformatical analysis this can be
achieved
also high throughput genomic technology
nowadays has become very rapid and major
tool for the study of breast cancer
the gene expression profiling has been
applied to many areas of research
from basic science to translational
science and also to identify
targets and treatments for them and
uh gene amplification occurs and
also uh like high throughput genomic
technology enables us
to see breast cancer from a
bioinformatical point of view
where we can analyzes we can analyze the
data set
and we can identify the markers the
sites where the mutation occur
and according to it we can device our
biomarkers
or the therapeutic drugs so next slide
please
yeah uh following transcriptomics and
proteomics
the large scale and high throughput
techniques uh help us to do further
treatments and prediction of the
outcomes
these things these include like sest
sage mps
these are a part of the techniques and
the gene expression profiles analyzes
the differential expression of the genes
differential
expressed genes are like those have a
difference or change
observed uh in their expression profiles
during
two experimental conditions one one is a
mutated condition and another in
normal conditions and also hub genes i
wanted to
say that hub genes are the genes with
higher correlations
so in breast cancer the most correlated
genes we can
tell them as hub genes and by
identifying the hub genes
we can identify the biomarkers and
like and following that path we can un
uh
identify the sites
through which the therapeutic drug can
be devised
so next slide
yeah so after we identify the changes
the mutated sequences and the analysis
that we will do
then uh the biomarkers and therapeutic
drugs
will be unleashed and they are enabled
due to the presence of bioinformatics
studies
definitely and molecular classification
of the breast cancer can be done
and dude by various microarray analysis
and by using bioinformatical approach
treatment and drugs for the best concern
nowadays has become very helpful and in
very less time
it is solved right now so yeah that's
it thank you
thank you for your insightful
information
i may throw it open to the audience if
you have any questions please put it
down in the chat box so they can answer
hi rudy uh vishwa has a question
yes please
thank you yes ma'am chances of breast
cancer
in male is very low than females
because the mammary glands are affected
which are not developed in
males so chances are quite low in males
for developing breast cancer and it is
mostly affected to females
so am i clearer i should explain more
okay thank you
thank you once again for presenting now
we will move on to the next
presenter that is me i am
and i would be presenting on two topics
today
the first one is precision medicine i
would be presenting on precision
medicine that is how it is useful and as
we have
the theme for cancer biology i would be
explaining it with the example of
skin cancer and further on i would also
explain like about five to six slides
about my current
present topic that is medulloblastoma
cancer project that i am working on
so first we will see about precision
medicine
so precision medicine is also known as
the personalized medicine which is
taking over the industry of
molecular medicine and bioinformatics
and that's why we call it the next
generation's future
to get familiarized with what
personalized medicine is
personalized medicine is a term that we
use to describe the individual treatment
a person gets according to his or her
genetic
makeup that is genotype the phenotype
that they express
the biomarkers and the psychological
characteristics that they possess
so personalized medicine is in kind of a
medicine that is given according to your
own characteristics
or the traits that a person prevails and
it is only particular for that kind of
an individual
and one personalized medicine could not
be taken by second individual because
individuals differ from each other in
terms of genotype
biomarkers and several other traits so
personalized medicine is a whole branch
that is prepared from huge clinical data
and bases that comprises of
combining the genomic profile the
proteomics profile the transcriptomics
epigenetic and microbiome
profile of an individual upon which the
conclusions are elucidated and later on
the personalized medicine for that
individual is made
to get more into depth about what
personalized medicine is branches like
phenomics genomics transcriptomics
and proteomics epigenomics and
microbiomics which are
all the sub branches of bioinformatics
are included
into precision medicine which together
makes one unit
so if there is a population of many i
hope you can see my cursor
for a more better and personalized care
for an healthy individual
we have to give the treatment one-on-one
that is for treating
one individual this would increase the
population levels of
health in terms of you know care the
kind of health we provide and kind of
the healthy nation that we prevail
through
there is a better risk stratification
that this risk
can be minimized errors can be minimized
and results can be greatly improved with
the use of precision medicine
though precision medicine is not still
widely accepted and used but however
we have found very much success rate in
precision medicine in different eras of
science molecular biomedicine and
biology
so why do we go to personalized medicine
instead of to regular medicine
that we go for so there are various
reasons that stands out
first is it improves disease detection
like personalized medicine is so apt
that it can detect a disease according
to your body type the kind of activities
you do your characteristics and further
on
and hence it is able to give an
effective treatment according to your
genotype which is very important point
in itself
it also helps us to shift the emphasis
in medicine
from reaction because normal medicines
we take we wait for it to get cured but
over here we can
go to one step further that is in
personalized medicine we need not need
to see the reaction but what we actually
experience is prevention we can also
customize disease prevention strategies
like they
advise us on what food we have to eat
the diet we have to
follow the practices we have to go
through while we are on personalized
medication
it also reduces the time and cost of the
nation that ones have to
spend beyond other kinds of medicines
and we have
also decreased rate of clinical trials
that everyone has to go through and we
all know this in times of covet 19
pandemic
we can also improve predict
susceptibility to
diseases like susceptibility to diseases
sometimes very hard to detect like it
takes three to four months and further
on
but with personalized medicine it is
very easy to detect such kinds of
diseases especially
cancer or melanoma or cardiovascular
diseases and further on
so we call it personalized medicine as a
multi-phased
approach that is because the risk
management
is very much lower we go through genetic
screening and testing to reveal certain
kinds of predisposition to this disease
and the
wonderful thing is that even before a
person
gets the diseases if it prevails
inherently or if it doesn't even prevail
in hereditary
one can get to know before the onset of
the disease that if he or
she is going to get this disease so risk
assessment factor is very low and
one could get preventive measures even
before the onset of the disease
second as i already talked about is
prevention the kind of behavior
lifestyle and practices
everyone and the doctor especially ask
us to follow
could be a great barrier in preventing
the onset of that diseases
the treatment becomes as effective as we
can go through that i already discussed
about
diagnosis is also becoming accurate with
the help of precision medicine
further on active monitoring that is the
management strategies of certain kinds
of health
and you know stereotypes of diseases
which are not controllable right now
could be possible with active management
of processing medicine
so if you have taken the example of
melanoma that is screen cancer
in personalized medicine like how do
they work
so brf is the human gene responsible for
the
production of the protein called as brf
this protein is usually involved in
sending signals inside the cells
to direct cell growth to form tumors and
from mutations
so in 2011 scientists came across a drug
that is known as vamura pheny that is a
bref protein inhibitor
so this test was later on approved for
the state uh treatment of la
late stage melanoma however around 60
percent of the patients
have brf mutation and treating them with
v
600 e mutation that is the short form of
memory memorabilif protein inhibitor was
found to be successful so this was my
presentation about personalized medicine
i would like the audience to ask me
questions
so that i can move on to the second
presentation
so
thank you so much
okay just in case you have any question
please put it down in the chat box while
i can start with my second presentation
because we have a time limit to follow
okay so my next presentation would be on
modular bastoma project that i have been
working on since a week it's just been a
week since i started this project
so i am on my stage of i'll just share
my screen
is my screen visible
yes we can see your screen okay yeah
so uh i have been interested in working
in medulloblastoma that is the
cancer of the brain so first just get
started with
medulloblastoma it is a rapidly growing
tumor of the cerebellum
the location of it is cerebellum and in
in terms of kids
or maybe 10 years of children
it is in the warmness of the cerebellum
it occurs in the lower rear portion of
the brain
and it is also known as the posterior
fossa so in some terms it is also known
as the cancer of the posterior fossa
it is all it is located below the
tentorium that is a thick membrane which
separates the large cerebral hemispheres
of the brain from the cerebellum
in children this cancer arises often
near the warmness which would be shown
in the next slide with the picture
depiction
so vermis is a narrow worm-like bridge
that connects the cerebellums and the
two sides together
in others this tumor occurs in the body
of the cerebellum especially towards the
edges and
continues to grow further
medulloblastoma is one of the fatal
cancers which
we have not been able to get a cure of
until now
it is a type of primary brain cancer in
children
and it originates in the part of the
brain that is towards the back and the
bottom
or the floor of the skull which proves
to be the cause that why
it is very fatal over here on the
picture of the right hand side you can
see the location of the tumors in the
tentorium
the orange dots that you can see
further on this is the picture of the
vermice which shows that this is the
warmest where the tumors occur
in children so tumors in children are
present in wormhills
there are certain kinds of histological
types of medulloblastoma
that are classified as classic
medulloblastoma
demoplastic nodular medulloblastoma
medulloblastoma
with extensive nodularity large cell
medulloblastoma
anaplastic medulloblastoma
medullomyoblastoma
and melanotic medulloblastoma each of
this nudeuloblastomas has their own
characteristics and specifications
but all of them have proved to be fatal
and there are not
enough you know disease preventions and
i must say
biomarkers developed yet in order to
prevent this
or have any kind of healthcare
prevention for this kind of disease
so what my exactly the problem question
is
there have been works that have shown
that cell cycle and p53 signaling
pathway play an important role in
invasion and progression
of medulloblastoma from normal samples
there are certain kinds of genes also
figured out like the ones stated over
here
ccna2 mad2l1
and further on that have been included
to
indulge in the invasion and progression
of medullobiostoma
now what is actually p53 pathway
so p53 pathway actually plays a key role
in controlling cell division and cell
death
and it is also thought to prevent
chromosomal replication during cell
cycle
so if there is any kind of dna damage or
apoptosis
p53 gene activates the p53 protein
in order to stop the replication of
damaged dna further on so it arrested
this cell cycle at g2 phase
so why we address this problem is
because if you want to find out the
relation of
mi rna and p53 protein pathway in
medulloblastoma which is largely
unknown we have to treat and identify mi
rna because the nature of mri rna and
all different types of medulloblastoma
is different
so identifying the underlying mechanism
between beneath
it would help to find certain kinds of
therapeutic biomarkers as well
and how mi rna regulates the activity
and function of p53 protein
it is thought to believe that mirna
controls p53 protein in various ways
that is by which mirna interact with p53
and it network in multiple layers also
they
activate and regulate the function of
p53 so direct repression which in
itself is a problem so further moving on
the three main types of questions and
hypotheses i would like to address is
how does mirna function in
in genes and proteins like is it by
upstream regulation or downstream
effectors
the second type of question i would like
to address is how does expression of
mir when in different different types of
medulloblastoma
like how why do they react differently
in different kind of modular bastama
is there is any aggressive state or is
there any normal states is that what i
want to find out by this second question
the third question is to identify mirna
as therapeutic biomarker by examination
of the role of p53 signaling pathway and
cell cycle
in development of medulloblastoma
eventually this forms my central
question that is the identification of
therapeutic biomarkers
now there are several ways by which
mirna
is also interconnected with p53 gene
protein
but again not much is known about this
and
i think that if we indulge into this
more we can
help at least someone to get rid of
medulloblastoma because it is very fatal
and 95 percent of death is experienced
with the persons who
suffer to medulloblastoma so coming
about data sets
now i'm on this stage of my process a
project where i have found data sets but
still the metadata analysis and
everything is yet to be done
but i have found two data sets one has
healthy control samples
that is six another and along with the
medulloblastoma samples from exosomes
and peripheral blood that is nine
samples
i've also have got medulloblastoma
samples from frozen tumor tissue
then i got the other kind of data set
that i have
is with healthy control sample six
medulloblastoma samples from
cerebrospinal fluid that is 25
and medulloblastoma samples from lepton
meninges
in metastasis state that is 34 samples
now i would like to further go on with
this project by
you know calculating the metadata and
further on i would like to work on this
project as well
so my presentation ends over here can i
have questions from
you guys
so i had a question so what exactly do
you mean by a therapeutic biomarker
a therapeutic biomarker is like over
here i mean
indication that a progression of
medulloblastoma has taken place or is
about to take place
so you mean this is an early biomarker
so you can yes
predictive biomarker yeah i wouldn't
call that a therapeutic biomarker
therapeutic biomarker means it's a
marker of
therapy that a particular type of
therapy will work
okay and you're more focused on a
diagnostic biomarker
to diagnose it earlier yes
kind of predictive biomarker
harpreet did you have any comments on
this
so have you looked at uh exactly the
diagnostic biomarker
may be the candidates that are available
already for the medulla blasto yes i
have gone through them but i haven't
included them in the slides no no i mean
uh when you're analyzing i mean have you
look at actually what are already
mi rna or rna biomarkers available
and what are their limitations
yes ma'am
so i've analyzed the biomarkers like
especially mirna biomarkers for
medulloblastoma
the limitations are that that they are
they are able to show the progression of
the biomarkers
like mir143 that is a predictive
prognostic biomarker
but it can also act as an oncogene or
tumor suppressors but the success rate
has not been calculated that further so
that's why
they are even confused with whether to
take this forward or not
so there's another question in the chat
do you see the chat with me
yes how are you planning to analyze your
data further
which tools are you using okay so for
my data i have these the data sets over
here i have
you know mentioned are all single
entries but i have another data set with
pair
and reads of mi rna with my sequencing
so that data i would like to analyze
mirna data
so that i can get to know that if they
have upstream regulation or downstream
regulation
and later on i would analyze this data
but
how would i go with this is not what i
am sure about because i have just
started with my project and it's not
even a week so i'm still exploring
are there any other questions for rugby
uh then i think we should um move on to
the next presenter thank you
yes so our
next presenter is clinton
he is our associate biolog
omics logic mentor who conducts the
sessions with
oncology programs associated with pine
biotech
he further has a great background in his
own education level he has done his
masters of bioinformatics from
university of qf
he has done his masters of cellular and
molecular medicine from
university of otawa and he has done his
bachelors of biological science from
carnegie mellon
university i would like to hand it over
to clinton
you can further share on your screen and
go ahead with your presentation thank
you
thank you ruffy i will share my
screen all right
so my my name is clinton kuna
uh as we mentioned i completed my
bachelor's
in carnegie mellon where i discovered my
passion for research
later on i decided to learn more about
life sciences
which is why i obtained two master's
degrees
one from the university of guelph and
the other from the university of
ottawa i am interested in translational
bioinformatics and i have a genuine
interest in cancer
therapeutics i
i worked at a hospital for two years
during my first master's in cancer
research
where i learned several basic research
techniques and
the introductory material and advanced
material related to
cancer biology
cancer is an extremely heterogeneous
disease
it's it's so vast
that the research is still ongoing to
solve this problem
we're learning more and more about how
complex it is with
greater molecular diagnostic techniques
to show you how complex cancer is
let me give you an example of my
master's project
so there are there are several proteins
that play different roles
depending on its context and the protein
that i
studied is called c20 like kinase or slk
it plays an important role in processes
such as proliferation
migration and apoptosis it affects
embryo development and is shown to play
a role in tumor genesis
this was studied in a new induced
mammary to
tumor model within mice and slk knockout
was shown to develop tumors faster
it and showed an increased expression of
sox10
an important biomarker in cancer
however in my own research which is an
extension of
the previous research we studied slk and
mouse embryonic fibroblasts
where slk knockout
was shown to reduce focal adhesion
turnover
itch it it turns out that slk plays
different
roles depending on its context
even though this shows a different
phenotype
because of red use migration versus
increased tumor genesis in the previous
study
it this this contrast shows how complex
cancer can be depending on its context
and how we have to be very careful
with the experimental design and data
analysis
to truly analyze its pathogen
cancers pathogenesis
research on slk is ongoing which is
similar to cancer every cancer is
different
and it's a challenge to determine where
those differences exist
we need more advanced methods to
determine why a knockout
reduces a process in one context but
increases it in another this master's
thesis
gave me more insight on
what needs to be solved and
i therefore i decided to do a
another masters in bioinformatics to
learn complex
analytical skills to solve these basic
research problems so
so i therefore i transition from basic
research to
bioinformatics i i
pure biology is good but those data
analytical skills can help us
derive meaningful relationships to solve
major problems bioinformatics has
exposed me to
a variety a variety of other fields
because of its interdisciplinary nature
such as statistics math and engineering
so my passion for biology
and programming and teaching because i
used to volunteer
and teach esl to people in my community
and that
slowly developed into a teaching career
then i taught biology sat
and then programming and it slowly
developed
so my passion for biology programming
and teaching
eventually led me to pine biotech
through a by meeting ilia
so as an omics logix bioinformatics
trainer
for the precision oncology program i
enjoy going through these important
pipelines which can be re irrelevant
for my understanding as well as the
learners
i personally believe that i've
contributed and
i've contributed to my learner's
research when i answered
their technical questions as a mentor
i enjoy working in the field of cancer
therapeutics
and i'm grateful to share my passion for
the field
as a bio as a master's graduate in
medicine
and bioinformatics i truly know the
transition
from basic research to bioinformatics
therefore i hope to make that transition
as easy as possible for my learners
there are several courses on the omics
logic website that expands upon
different topics
within bioinformatics and learning
and learning and teaching these courses
helped me become a better
bioinformatician
due to the lesson preparation which
involves on
great understanding of the course
material
therefore i look forward to teaching
future omics logic alumni
and i hope um if you have any questions
please let me know
so how could you recommend for somebody
who's getting interested in oncology to
get started
with a research project
so if um
it did i'd say you should do a needs
assessment to see where your weaknesses
lie
usually if if you're coming from a
biology background
biology should be your strongest point
therefore i would
maybe take some introductory to
um our courses or python just like
there may there's some courses in the
omics logic website that pertain to the
the foundational technical knowledge to
get into the field as well as the
introductory
introduction to bioinformatics course
which helps you
gain those foundational skills to
go deeper into bioinformatics when you
have to deal with
pipeline development and understanding
why
certain steps are important like the
the heavy technical stuff i hope that
answers your question
thank you clinton for your wonderful
presentation
we definitely have a lot more to learn
from you
i would also like to thank all the
presenters for today and the speakers as
well for their valuable time and
insightful information
i would like to pass it on to bipsam
for further insights into certain
certain training programs
beeps over to you thank you
thank you so much and it has been
wonderful to
see all the presenters present their
different research ideas and proposals
and on this
note as we have a lot of participants
today who are interested specifically in
research
i only want to take five more minutes of
your time
and continue with this presentation
and also introduce everybody to some
resources so my name is beepsha biswas
and i'm the omixlogic community manager
and i work with students researchers
faculty
from all different parts of biology
bioinformatics biotechnology backgrounds
and what i have is an insight into how
this entire process of research works
and i have been working with
students like you researchers like you
for a while now
and what my main objective is to help
anybody who comes
into this community that we have which
is our bioinformatics community
achieve the personal goals that each
person would have
so what i first wanted to talk a little
bit about is the omics logic programs
now
what we saw presenters present today are
some research projects
now as we understand that these research
projects
come only after you have gone through a
certain
degree of training it could be any kind
of degree training that you're taking at
your university college or your
school level or it could also be some of
the additional training programs and
what we do at pine biotech is offer
training in multi-omics analysis so what
we try to teach
all of our participants is you know
how you can work with different kinds of
formic state and right now
we are working with thousands of users
around the world we actually have more
than tens and thousands of users who are
participating in programs like this and
we work locally with users in us
africa and india where we are involved
with universities
involved with local training
institutions
and also with students who are joining
in this does not mean that
other students are not joining in we are
also actively working with
other students who join in on their own
from different parts of the world
so these are some of our you know local
chapters as you can see here
and the next part is our educational
program
so what we have is called omics logic so
you can understand by the name is that
these programs teach you about the logic
of different kinds of comics data types
now i know that most of you are familiar
with one or the other type of formics
data right
so maybe you can put down in the chat
box what are the different domic data
types that everybody here knows
so please put those comics data types in
the chat box and
i can take it from there so maybe rudy
you can put in one name
to start with and also encourage
everybody else to put in their comments
and what we actually hope for is that
you know in as part of all of these
discussions that we have
every week in the club all of the
participants are able to participate in
these discussions
so i hope am i audible
okay rudy okay puja is writing
epigenomics great
rudi genomics okay maham writes
proteomics wonderful
so you see there are so many types of
omics data that you all are familiar
with
damilola writes metagenomics she or she
writes transcriptomics
perfect and wonderful so we all are
familiar with these different types of
comics data and that is
exactly what we do with our programs so
we try to teach you the logic so i will
introduce you to some of these programs
for example what clinton showed you
today
that he is training students who are in
the precision oncology program where we
are talking about
precision medicine for cancer research
even today's topic was
on cancer biology right so then we are
trying to
teach our students who are coming and
enjoying the program how they can
utilize
this particular kind of formic data to
answer some of the questions that they
have and how do we do this
so you would see here highlighted in
black that we have some interactive
online tools
and i will also again introduce you to
those tools in a moment
now what we do is that we first start by
introducing you
to these courses online so
every student who comes in for the first
time they are introduced to the courses
they start learning from the courses as
well as online sessions that we have
and then we also introduce you to our
research grade analysis platform so this
is a cloud-based platform called the
server t bio info
and what we do as part of that platform
is give you access so each
student has research access to that
platform
where they are able to take data from
publicly available data sets for example
you saw that rudby has a data in mind
now she will have to
understand how to work with that data so
she also has gone through some of these
courses
as is shiroshi and shiraji who are also
going through some of these courses
right now so
they will be learning and then
understanding whether
uh on that data that they are looking
for
or the kind of analysis that they have
to do so this is exactly what we hope
that we will
help you learn so that in the future any
type you are
say you have any kind of problem you
want to solve
using crn you seek data or it could be a
metagenomic data you are able to do that
so we will be teaching you the logic we
will be working with you
you will have mentors here we have dr
harpreet here
uh ilya dr mohit mazumdar clinton
and also there are other several mentors
who are ready to walk you through
these different steps on how to achieve
that goal of where you also have
a research project and not only research
project
so the next step is once you complete
these research projects
is like you know presenting them so here
are just some of these
examples of these research projects
and we take it to the next level where
you can also complete the project
and present them so one of the things
that we do as part of this club is you
know present
a lot we ask everybody to make sure that
they have a presentation ready
they can speak clearly because when you
have a research idea and you work on
something it's not
enough if you just you know have that
idea you have worked on your project you
need to tell it to the whole world
so we go through with our research
fellows with our participants
so that they can present they can
prepare presentations they can
do video video recordings of those
presentations so we walk through them we
correct anybody whoever
has and we identify those gaps so that
you become a better speaker
you can present them and you can follow
through a step-by-step process which
also i will be showing you
very shortly so these were just some
presentation
poster presentations that we have had in
the past
and we do hope that anybody else who is
interested would be able
to go forward and work through now
let me introduce you to the platform
as well as some of the resources so we
have this platform called learn.oxlogic
it is our educational platform
and what we have in this platform are
a number of different courses and
the best part is that this platform
is free so you can log into this
platform and once you create an account
you will always have
access so you do not lose access to the
platform
and if i'm to take a look at one of
these courses so say for example
genomics
you would find that there are several
lessons so many of these lessons are
free while some of these lessons are
paid
so i would encourage anybody who is
interested in learning more about
any of these topics be it genomic speed
metagenomics
or even transcriptomics please go
through and
there are several other lessons also
here
so please feel free to look at those
lessons as well
and ask us any questions you can put
those questions down in the whatsapp
group that we have for
psionics so that we are able to get back
on the lessons with you
if you are already a part of our program
you know that we have slack
channels you are there with us on skype
as well as you have our email id so
please feel free to utilize those and
ask
as many questions as you can so one of
the things that as i mentioned that i've
been working
for a while with so many students
researchers and everybody else and one
of the things that i
feel is missing is that most of the time
you know
students don't ask us questions and then
they wait
till the end and maybe you know then we
say that okay you have to change this
and they're like you know i have been
thinking for a while
so what i encourage is that whenever you
have a question
please ask us that question so that
maybe at that
moment in time we are not able to help
you but we'll also go
study a little more learn from your
question
and give you the right answer that you
can then
uh you know use to learn from to maybe
you know
correct your project or any other thing
so
it is a learning experience for
everybody involved
in the process and i hope that you know
this would give you an
idea of how things are working so
definitely these courses
are available for everyone to take
freely so please sign up to the platform
it's a very easy way to sign up
i will show you out so let me log out
here quickly
and show you how to log in so once you
go log in here to the platform
you would come to this page so you can
either create an account so my is
already saved here
or you can also utilize any of your
social media logins to login
so i already have my email id saved up
so once i sign in
i'm directly brought to the course page
so you can continue to
do this and also you can track your own
progress
so if i click on my email id
i'm able to see what i have done so far
right so i think it's a very interactive
way for you to learn it
i also encourage you to go ahead and
update your profiles here you can see
your
activity on different dates so please
feel free to test yourself as well while
you are
going through that process and the next
thing that i wanted to
just introduce everybody to are the
projects so we heard today
about some project proposals as well as
project ideas
that our research fellows campus
ambassadors
have here for you know what they want to
do in terms of cancer biology or cancer
research
here are several different projects that
have been
done and completed by students who come
from
high school like amelia and i think
today we
have both dr gansha and
also dr chupuka in the chat box so
hello dr chupuka so dr gansha and
chupuka had
uh collaborated on this project on sars
cove too
and you can also watch this project on
youtube so all of these
are youtube links you can directly watch
them
and here we have another project on
triple negative breast cancer
so there are different projects not only
related to cancer but on
for example on neurodegenerative
diseases
on metagenomics etc so we'll be
continuing to update this page with any
other projects that our research
community completes
and puts forward and i do encourage that
everybody who is present here today is
also
going to go ahead and propose their own
project work on their own project
and anytime you would need any kind of
assistance please feel free to reach out
to us and we can be reached at
marketing at pine dot bio for any kind
of questions regarding
how to approach a project or if you have
any specific
concerns related to the courses
and the next part that i would want to
introduce you
to is the omics logic program so as i
mentioned that we have omics logic
programs on different topics
that go on throughout the year so at
different points of the year we
different months we take up a lot of
these programs
and now that you know we are at the end
of an academic year
and summer is starting i believe that
many of the students would be finishing
their
exams in their colleges universities so
it's a good time for you to focus on
something that would help you to learn
more
or advance more and learn more about
buying for matrix if that is an area
that you're
specifically interested in so this is
the link
where we keep on updating about any of
the programs that we have
and please feel free to ask me any
questions that you may have of course
the first one
is the research fellowship this is a
program that we offer
all around the year for any student who
is interested in working
on their own novel research project
so again to note i use the word novel
because
the research project idea is actually
proposed
by the student so we do not propose that
idea we do not make you work on
our project you propose an idea
and we work to train you first and the
second step
is asking you to present your own
project like you see that rudy has done
today she's presenting a project idea
then we work
with you to finish that idea like it
could be that you are answering a very
broad question so we would try to do
uh something very simple so that you can
start by
looking at a problem maybe that you know
a research paper that you have read
must have missed out on or there is a
gap in that research
so we will take up those points and work
with you to answer those questions so
this is like
for three months or six months you can
apply for a research fellowship
then we have a workshop in collaboration
with the all india institute
of medical sciences new delhi and this
would be
a two-day workshop
starting on april 23rd
and april 24th so this is also a
workshop that you can
sign up for if you're interested in
learning more about
lymphoma so lymphoma is the topic that
we are going to cover in
this workshop and third is
this program that we are running in
collaboration with the nobuji memorial
institute of medical sciences
in ghana and the focus of this
is on transcriptomics
or rna-seq so this program specifically
starts on the
16th of april yesterday we had a free
webinar which is now
available for everyone to watch on our
youtube channel
so please feel free to watch and if you
want to request a video you cannot find
it you can again reach out to me at
marketing at pine dot bio and i will be
able to
share with you the video of this session
so we are going to be starting this one
month training program on april 16
and really working work on focusing
about uh
infectious diseases so talking about
malaria covert 19 mainly as part of this
program and other infectious diseases
we also have other rna-seq training
programs which
talk about uh more about cancer biology
or
any other applications of rna-seq
to different kinds of biological
problems
and the next program that we have
upcoming
is on biomedical drug discovery so this
is a
joint collaborative program with pine
biotech
uh faba pharma toppers and
a few other collaborators and this will
be a four month program
and what we are doing here is we are
going to be taking again
intensive uh small small programs that
we are going to do
starting with genomics then
transcriptomics
then r and python and structural biology
so if you are interested in either of
these programs
please feel free to fill out the form
and at the end you can choose which
program you're interested in
and then click on submit so then you
would receive the details
regarding this program so please feel
free to ask me
any question that you have about any of
the topic that
i spoke about today and what i wanted to
show you is an interesting thing
of how we plan our research programs
so as you saw that projects and as i've
been speaking about the projects which
are completed
so what we do is we follow this research
process
right where we start first by the
training
that we are covering in the programs and
the courses
the next step that a participant has to
do
is identify a topic by conducting
literature review
then identify a data set for example
today
clinton asked rudby why did she choose
the data set that she has chosen right
so
you would need to understand why you
have to choose a certain data set
why does it align to your project idea
so that
is quite an intensive process and
therefore we are here to
be your mentor and guide you with that
process in case
you are not able to identify that
then the next step would be once you
have identified the data set and
everything
to prepare a table of metadata that
would have the names of the samples
group names etc
then the next step is to present three
to five slides
of the idea that you have like we saw
rudy present she has an
idea right now on how to work on medulla
blastoma but
she is not very well defined the idea is
not yet defined the idea is there she
has a certain
interest in that topic she has found
some data sets but she still needs to
identify
what is the research topic that she has
right so
these are how we move through so there
are these 20 steps that we are following
through and it's a very step-by-step and
defined process and
as you see most of the participants who
have followed through these steps
have had this outcome where they are
able to present
and then translate it some of our
participants that we will be updating
here are also going to have poster
presentations
they'll be speaking at conferences so
you can imagine that once you have a
project done
you can take it from to anywhere so it's
up to you how much research
you want to do some of the times our
participants
are very happy completing a project and
you know then applying or adding it to
their cvs
and it's of course very helpful for
career growth
the other times they're also interested
in pursuing further research
in the topic and identifying any other
gaps that they may have
in the answer in answering the question
that they were trying to answer
and go and research for it for years as
well
and then you can present it you can
attend
some seminars where you can like you
know present it to a larger community
and not just you know very localized
community and what we will try to do
is help you present it in our meeting so
we continue to have these webinars
we continue to have these meetings that
we have as part of psionics club
and we welcome you all to join this from
time to time
and now again if you have any questions
please feel free to ask those questions
to me
and if you do not have any questions
then thank you all again for joining
today it was wonderful to listen to
all the presenters and i do hope to see
more participation from everybody in
this club and again
please feel free to reach out to us
anytime thank you so much
thank you rudhvi and thank you everybody
else
for participating in today's session
you